Pasture is the single
largest type of land
on the surface of the Earth today,
thanks to our taste for meat and dairy.
Just over a quarter of all land
is used for livestock.
That's more than forests
or farm fields or anything else.
Most of that land is best for ruminants,
such as cows,
that can digest high-fiber feed
such as grass and straw.
However, the process by which grass
and fiber is broken up
in the stomachs of cows
and other grazing ruminants
has a byproduct, methane,
a potent greenhouse gas.
Despite what you might have heard
about methane and cows,
most of the methane
is actually burped out,
not through the back end.
(Laughter)
And that represents
about two billion tons
of carbon dioxide equivalent per year,
or more than four percent of our annual
global greenhouse gas emissions.
We have a methane problem from cows.
So how can you reduce these methane burps?
My colleagues and I
may have found a solution.
Seaweed!
Let me explain.
A couple of years ago,
an article was published
by Rob Kinley and colleagues
that showed almost complete
elimination of methane
when seaweed was added
to chopped grass in the lab.
Great.
But as an agricultural researcher,
I know lots of additives
work well in the lab,
but not in real animals.
But there was something
different about seaweed
and the way in which it reduced methane.
So we thought we should
test this in live animals.
In collaboration with Joan Salwen,
an entrepreneur,
and colleagues from
James Cook University and CSIRO,
we decided to conduct a small experiment
to determine the amount of seaweed
we might need to use.
This was the first ever
experiment in dairy cattle,
and we had no idea how much to give them.
So we started with about 60 grams per day,
going up to 250 grams.
Mind you, this was mixed in
with 25 kilograms of their feed.
One of the graduate students
I work with, Breanna Roque,
trapped their methane burps.
(Laughter)
In that first experiment,
the emissions were reduced
by up to 67 percent.
(Applause)
And I thought at first,
the equipment must have
malfunctioned, but it was real.
But we are left with more
questions than answers.
Would the microbes
in the gut get used to it
and start producing methane over time?
Would the seaweed be stable
over a long period of time in storage?
Would the taste be affected
and the cows turn up their noses?
Or would the seaweed affect
the cows's health or milk production?
So we teamed up again
to conduct another trial.
Over a five-month period,
we saw the seaweed
that was harvested three years prior
reduce emissions by over 80 percent.
(Applause)
Our colleagues in Australia,
they saw up to 98 percent
reduction in a similar trial.
That kind of reduction
is simply staggering.
And in the graph,
you see methane emissions
in three levels of intake.
So the first line
is for cattle with no seaweed,
The second line is for cows
that were supplemented
with about 30 to 40 grams of seaweed.
And the last one is for cows
supplemented with
about 60 to 80 grams of seaweed.
As you can see, as you increase
the amount of seaweed,
you see a reduction in methane emissions.
We have also seen
an improvement in bulking up
of the beef cattle
with no adverse health effects.
So it’s a win for the environment;
it's a win for the farmers and consumers.
A panel of 112 people got to taste steak
made from steers offered
seaweed and control.
And they did not detect any difference.
We also did a nutritional
quality of the meat,
and we found no difference between
animals that were offered seaweed
and the control.
So how does it work?
Some seaweeds contain ingredients
that directly inhibit microbes
in the cow’s gut from forming methane
without interfering with food digestion.
The amount of methane produced
is dependent on how much
the animal is eating
and what's in the diet.
And as such,
previous efforts to reduce
methane emissions
focused on changing their diets
or improving forage quality.
And we do have potential solutions
other than seaweed
to reduce methane emissions.
We looked at additives to feed,
such as 3-NOPs,
reduce emissions by about 30 percent.
Even garlic and citrus extract
can reduce methane burps
by over 20 percent
without affecting
animal health and productivity.
Now you may ask:
Why not stop eating
beef and drinking milk?
Audience member: Yeah!
(Laughter)
EK: That would be a good question.
So adopting a plant-based diet
with supplements
may help shrink
a person's carbon footprint
in high-income countries like the US.
But, you know, a lot of people
are not going to do that.
And for the rest of the world,
these foods are needed
to provide key nutrients,
such as vitamin B12 and vitamin A,
which are critical for brain function,
for vision and immunity.
These are found almost exclusively
in beef and milk.
In this graph, you see different countries
with their annual meat consumption
per capita on the bar graph,
and then you see the dots
representing the stunting rate
in children below the age
of five years old.
And countries that have lower
consumption of methane
are associated with higher
incidence of stunting.
I know this firsthand.
Growing up in Eritrea,
I loved milk and meat
when you could get it,
which wasn't often.
Even as a kid, I always wondered
how a cow, eating just grass,
produces nutritious milk I love to drink.
And that wonder pushed me
into a career to understand
and improve livestock production
so that people in low-income countries
do not suffer with stunting
and other nutrient-deficiency diseases.
(Applause)
So what now?
We know seaweed can work.
But the cultivation of the specific
seaweed has been a barrier.
It's not so easy to farm
asparagopsis taxiformis.
But there are a number of efforts
going on at the moment
to scale up production.
Blue Ocean Barns is growing
seaweed in Hawaii already,
and they estimate that there will be
enough production to feed all cattle
in the US by 2030.
All we need now
is for governments to step up
and facilitate the use
of these methane-busting feed additives.
Cattle industries in some countries
have already committed
to climate neutrality by 2050.
But if we can get these
feed-additive innovations
into cow stomachs earlier,
we can cut methane burps significantly.
Given that methane only lasts
in the atmosphere for a decade or so,
we could even slow global warming
in the short term.
Yes, we have a methane problem from cows,
but we may have seaweed
and other solutions
for these methane burps,
helping us provide meat and dairy
while maintaining a safe climate.
Thank you.
(Applause)